[موسيقى]
هل فعلا لم يتحدث في الامريكيون الى
القياده التونسيه انذاك بالمطلق ولا على
اي مستوى في تلك الفتره لم يعني لم تكون
هنالك اتصالات في الفتره الاخيره
[موسيقى]
التي كانت معانيه بمنشورات ويكيليكس وهي
تجميد الاتصال مش العلاقات تجميد
الاتصالات هذا من ناحيه ولكن البروسيس او
المسام
سابق لان هي كانت عندما
تقابلت معها
هي كانت في جوله يعني احاطه بما يجري هذا
مقالته
قالته بوضوح يعني يوميه وكانت على اتصال
حتى ببعض اعترف تونسيه كانت موجوده التقطت
مع بعض البعض منهم يعني لو كان هناك
الولايات المتحده كانت تريد ان تغير هذا
يعني التوازنات
[موسيقى]
يونس لم تقبل مثلا
امام التحديات الجديده للشبكات الارهابي
الى اخرها انت ان تحدث الافريكون في
الاراضي التونسيه وحتى في اراضي يعني
المغرب العربي ككلوا الاتحاد المغاربي
وهذا مطروح من ايام كونداليزا رايس ومن
ايام يعني قبل قبل الامريكي تحديدا والرفض
التونسي شو هو بالضبط
[موسيقى]
كنت انا في التجمع
وامين قال التجمع الدستوري ديمقراطي الحزب
الحاكم على الحزب الحاكم
وكان معي في وفد مشينا الولايات المتحده
وكنت اتصلنا ببعض النواب وتسنى بمناسبه
نيويورك توصلنا به وتسمى بالخصوص
اندرس
النائب وكاتب الدوله وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي اللي عنده شؤون الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا
بتاع الارهاب تحدي الاسلامي
الاسلام يعني مش تحدي الاسلامي تحدي
الاسلام السياسي
رؤيه تونس هو ان تونس تحتاج الى شيء من
الوقت لتدرس
ما بداته في بدايه التسعينات او اواخر
الثمانينات من اصلاحات
ولكن
وقتها احسست
بوضوح انا واقف موقف الامريكان هو دائما
ادمجهم في اللعبه السياسيه
[موسيقى]